Professor Charles
Bailyn: Okay,
let's start--let's see,
we started talking about black
holes last time,
and there's now going to be a
problem set that is going to be
available later today,
due next week.
And I should also point that
I've put together this website
on black holes.
Actually, some of the help
sheets already send you to that
website.
And I'll put a link on the
classes server as a whole,
but here it is as an actual
URL, cmi.yale.edu/bh for black
holes.
And that website kind of serves
as a sort of online textbook for
this part of the course.
And so, you have something
written down to look at for this
whole section of the course.
And, as you'll see,
many of the things we'll be
talking about are actually
discussed on that website,
as well.
So, you can find out more
information there.
Okay, so I--last time,
I defined a black hole.
This is simply something where
the escape velocity is faster
than the speed of light.
Or, alternatively,
and this is--amounts to the
exact same thing,
the radius of the object is
less than the Schwarzschild
radius,
which is defined for an object
of any given mass.
And this isn't particularly
extraordinary or interesting,
as long as the speed of light
isn't particularly extraordinary
or interesting.
And one of the things that
happens when you start talking
about relativity is that it
turns out the speed of light is
a very important quantity.
So this--these are interesting
because the speed of light is
interesting.
And, we'll talk in a minute
about how all this arises,
but one of the interesting
things about the speed of light
is that you can't go any faster.
It's the speed limit,
and no physical process can
make you go faster than the
speed of light.
So, c is fastest
velocity possible.
And the consequence of that is,
supposing you have one of these
black hole things--so,
here's some object,
and it's got some radius.
And its radius and its mass are
such that the escape velocity,
here, is greater than the speed
of light.
You could imagine that around
it is a kind of imaginary
sphere.
Let's put it in dots.
And this is the sphere where
the escape velocity is equal to
the speed of light.
And you remember what the
formula for the escape
velocity--V</
i>_esc is equal to
2GM / R,
the square root of 2GM /
R.
And so, if on the surface of
this object, the escape velocity
is greater than that of light,
if you keep moving out,
R will keep getting
bigger.
And so, eventually you'll come
to a point in space where the
escape velocity is equal to the
speed of light,
and this is called the event
horizon.
And the reason it's called that
is because, if nothing can go
faster than the speed of light,
what it means is that any event
that takes place inside this
imaginary sphere can't radiate
any information about what's
going on to the outside,
because this--the escape
velocity's greater than the
speed of light.
Light can't escape,
and because nothing else can go
faster than the speed of light,
nothing else can escape.
And so, no information of any
kind can come--comes from inside
the event horizon to the
outside.
And so, in a certain
philosophical sense,
this event horizon sort of
constitutes an edge of the
Universe,
because nothing that happens
inside can affect what happens
outside in any way.
You can't see in.
You can't detect anything that
goes on inside.
No event inside this event
horizon can tell us
what's--about itself or--and
we--there's no--in principle,
there's no way we can find out
anything about what happens
inside an event horizon.
It turns out that this rather
grandiose statement,
that the event horizon
constitutes an edge of the
Universe, has a mathematical
meaning as well.
The great physicist Stephen
Hawking--you may have heard
about him.
He's the guy in the wheelchair.
His --shorthand--his--one of
his great discoveries was to
demonstrate that the mathematics
of the event horizon is actually
very similar to the mathematics
of another edge of the
Universe--namely The Big Bang,
which is the start of the
Universe in time.
And so, it turns out that this
statement that this constitutes
an edge of the Universe is not
just a philosophical statement
having to do with defining the
Universe as something we might
eventually,
possibly, know something about,
or be influenced by,
but also has a mathematical
meaning,
as well.
And so, the way you have to
think about the Universe is as a
kind of Swiss cheese.
There are holes in it.
There are holes in it,
which aren't part of our
Universe, where these little
event horizons cut pieces out.
And it's this kind of thing
that gives black holes the kind
of extraordinary aura of mystery
that they sort of have in
everyday life.
Various strange things happen
inside the event horizon.
And now I better pause,
because I just contradicted
myself, right?
Because I said a minute ago
that you can't find out anything
about what happens in the event
horizon,
and now I'm about to tell you
what happens inside an event
horizon.
Okay, so it--we're ten--we're
eight minutes into class and
already I'm contradicting
myself.
And so, let me explain exactly
what I mean by this.
Here's what you do if you want
to make statements about what's
going on the inside of one of
these things.
What you do is you take the
equations that apply outside the
event horizon.
You assume that the same
equations are going to apply
inside the event horizon.
Turns out, the mathematics of
these things,
and I'll show you an example of
this next week,
the mathematics of these things
do very bizarre things at the
event horizon.
But mathematicians are smart
people.
One can cope with these kinds
of problems.
It tends--you tend to have
problems like,
everything gets divided by zero
right at the event horizon.
But, as you may recall,
if you've done a good
pre-calculus course,
there are ways you can get past
those kinds of infinities--but
everything goes haywire.
But, if you make the assumption
that the same set of equations
apply inside the event horizon
as outside,
you can then manipulate those
equations, interpret the results
as if the symbols mean the same
thing inside as they do outside,
and then make statements about
what happens inside the event
horizon.
And this looks a lot like
physics, right?
Because you've got a bunch of
equations and,
you know, some of them stand
for time,
and some of them stand for
space, and energy,
and all this good stuff.
And you can do manipulations of
those equations,
and then you can make
statements about what happens.
But, it looks like physics--you
can make an argument that it
isn't actually physics,
because you're making an
assumption that those equations
apply inside there,
and that's an assumption that
is un-testable.
Even in principle,
un-testable,
because you can't ever get any
information about what's going
on in there to see if those
really are the right equations.
And so, here's something where
it looks like physics but,
depending on what you define
the limits of physics to be--and
this is kind of a deep
philosophical question that we
won't go too far into--it might
actually be something that,
while interesting,
it is really something else.
So, just a couple of examples
of the kinds of things that you
can deduce from the mathematics
about what goes on inside event
horizons.
One--here's something.
All matter with R less
than the Schwarzschild
radius--oh, this distance,
here, will always be the
Schwarzschild radius,
by definition,
because that's the radius away
from an object where the escape
velocity is equal to the speed
of light.
So, all matter inside the
Schwarzschild radius collapses
to a single point in a finite
amount of time;
so, it doesn't take forever to
do this.
And that points--since it's got
a lot of matter but no volume,
that's what a point is--that's
a point of infinite density.
And this is sometimes called a
singularity.
And you can see some of the
problems with doing mathematics
inside event horizons.
If you try and calculate the
density for this--density is
mass over volume.
If you've got a bunch of mass
in a single point,
the volume is zero,
and you've just divided by
zero, and you're in all kinds of
trouble.
So it--everything collapses
down to a point of infinite
density.
There's no force strong enough
to stop this from happening.
You can't set up a rocket
system to keep yourself in orbit
or keep yourself from falling
down.
Partly that--one way of
understanding that is that the
energy you would exert in trying
to hold yourself up has a mass
equivalent.
You'll recall that E =
mc^(2),
so for a given amount of energy
there's a mass equivalent.
The extra mass just pulls you
down more.
So you can't--by expending
energy, you can't hold yourself
up inside a singularity,
so everything collapses.
It's also true--this is the
kind of thing you see in popular
accounts of black holes.
The statement is sometimes
made: the properties of space
and time are reversed.
That's a weird thing to say.
What could this possibly mean?
Well, let's see.
It's related actually to what I
just said, that everything falls
down to a singularity.
In an ordinary situation,
we can move around in space.
I can expend energy and move
all around in space.
I can move back and forth.
I could jump up and down,
see--but you don't have a lot
of choice of where you go in
time.
You move forward in time at the
rate of one day per day,
right?
And you can expend a lot of
energy trying to avoid that,
and it won't actually do you
any good.
So, inside an event horizon you
fall down to a singularity.
And, as I said,
you can expend a lot of energy
but it doesn't change your
trajectory in space.
So, what happens when you fire
off your rocket?
Well, in principle,
providing you believe in all
these equations,
you could, in principle,
move around in time.
And, this is why the science
fiction writers like black holes
so much, because it's a kind of
scientifically-certified time
machine.
You go into the event horizon.
You turn on your energy pack
and move all around in time.
And then, what they forget to
tell you is that you're inside
an event horizon,
so it does you no good,
because you can't come out
again.
And so, then,
the effort is to try and figure
a way that you could have this
nice effect of the time machine
without having an event horizon.
And, in particular,
there's some interest in
whether one can have what's been
described as a naked
singularity.
A naked singularity is a
singularity with no event
horizon around it,
so that you could get in down
to where all the weird physics
happens,
and then come back out again.
Hawking proposed what he called
the Cosmic Censorship Theorem.
That is the statement that
naked singularities are not
allowed.
And so, hence,
censorship can't have naked
singularities.
And there is,
to this day,
some dispute over whether that
will turn out to be true,
in general, or not.
And you can go on in this vein.
You can talk--you can talk on
and on about the extraordinary
physical events and properties
that these things might actually
have.
And what you have to keep in
mind, as you're doing this,
is that there's a limit to how
much this could ever,
even in principle,
be realized in real life.
You know, you fall into one of
these wormholes that they like
to have on the science
fiction--in the science fiction
stories,
and you'd better have some very
tricky physics if you're going
to be able to come back out
again.
And that's not something that
the science fiction world
typically dwells on.
Although, it is
interesting--you know the movie
Contact?
So, this is based on Carl
Sagan's novel of the same name.
And, one of the things that
happens late in this--this is
the first use,
I think,
in science fiction,
of the concept of a worm hole,
where you fall into a black
hole and you fall out again
somewhere totally different in
space and time.
And there's an interesting
story about this--that what
happened, supposedly,
was that Sagan,
when he was writing his novel,
got to the point in the novel
and he needed something to
happen for plot reasons,
in order to move the plot
forward.
And he--Sagan himself was not
an expert in relativity,
so he called up one of his
friends,
who was a guy named Kip Thorne,
one of the most famous general
relativity people.
He said, look,
here's what has to happen in my
novel.
Give me some science jargon so
that--that will make this work.
And Thorne, who was a very
smart guy, thought about this
for a while, and came up with
this concept of the wormhole
that,
you know, you fall into a black
hole here and you fall out of it
again on the other side.
Then, Thorne went away and
thought about this for a while.
At least, this is what he
claims in his book,
and said, you know,
this might work.
And a whole series of
scientific papers flowed from
that.
So, here is a place where art
pushed science.
Art in the form of science
fiction, if you consider that
art, pushes science--pushes
science forward,
rather than the other way
around--quite unusual,
in that case.
All right, so,
all of this is great.
But I want to focus a little
bit on what does it actually
mean?
These grand statements that one
makes about, you can't go faster
than the speed of light,
space and time are reversed,
and so forth.
What actually underlies those
statements?
And to what extent are these
sort of spectacular kinds of
phenomena actually realized in
the real world?
So, I'm an observational
astronomer.
What right do I even have to
talk about black holes,
the number one characteristic
of which is that you can't see
them at all?
So, that's where we're going to
go in a minute,
and to do that,
we have to talk about
relativity--special relativity
and general relativity--because
those are the theories that
underlie all of this.
So, before we go plunging into
that let me pause for questions
at this point.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes,
you should be.
Yes, so the--a little confused
about why space and time are
reversed.
Let me not answer that now,
because there's,
there's math next week,
which will make that a little
bit clearer.
I think it is a legitimate
question, not just to ask why
are space and time reversed,
but what that even could mean.
And we'll get back to that in a
little while.
Let me--yes, go ahead.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Right,
and doesn't--so,
supposing you have,
for example,
a neutron star that's a little
bit smaller than its event
horizon,
why wouldn't it just stay there
inside its event horizon,
rather than collapsing down?
And again, this is a
calculation that I don't think I
can demonstrate for you,
but it comes about because the
energy, the pressure forces that
would have to hold it up,
actually also contribute to the
mass of the thing.
And if you then compute the
balance, the hydrostatic
equilibrium that we were talking
about last time,
it never works.
It can't work,
because the amount of energy
required to hold it up is so
great that the mass equivalent
is going to generate additional
gravitational forces.
And if this were a different
kind of course,
I'd do the calculation,
but let's not go there.
Yes?
Student: Time originally
goes forward,
right?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah,
I would say.
No, no that's fine--yeah.
Student: It can go
backward?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well,
the thing is,
in our normal situation,
we have no choice about where
we go in time.
And the statement that I made,
which I didn't back up in any
way to--that a rational person
would really want to believe
me--but let me make this
statement again.
Inside the event horizon,
you can move around in time.
You don't necessarily have to
go forward.
And that is the thing--that is
the piece of the picture that
the science fiction writers tend
to hone in on.
And so, you know,
the statement is made about
relativity.
And I'll make this explicit in
a little while.
Time is the fourth dimension.
There are three space
dimensions, one time dimension,
and you can do all sorts of
calculations that way.
But it's perfectly clear,
just from everyday life,
that the time dimension is not
the same as the space
dimensions,
because we don't have the
opportunity to move around in
them.
So, it must be true that in a
certain sense,
time--the time dimension,
if you want to call it that,
of the space-time continuum,
must somehow behave differently
from the spatial components.
And they do,
and I'll show you why in a
little while.
And that behavior is reversed
between space and time inside
the event horizon.
Things that are positive terms
in the equation become negative,
and vice versa.
And as I say,
we'll actually--I'll actually
write some of this down.
Yeah?
Student: Since,
like, nothing could escape--can
escape from a black hole,
is one of, like,
the possible,
you know, scenarios for the end
of the Universe,
be--if --all matter being in
the form of black holes?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: All--okay,
so since nothing can escape
from a black hole,
is that a possible end of the
Universe?
Yes.
One of the potential ways the
Universe could evolve--the
Universe is expanding right now.
Again, this is now in the third
part of the course,
we'll talk about this.
The Universe is expanding,
but it's got a lot of matter in
it.
So, in principle,
it could stop expanding and
collapse.
You could ask the question,
"Does the Universe expand
faster than its own escape
velocity, or not?"
And this is a question that
cannot only be asked,
but answered.
It could expand,
slow down, stop,
fall back together again.
And, if that happened at a
certain point when it fell
together, the whole Universe
would be inside its event
horizon.
Now, how that would affect
those of us who are inside is a
little less clear.
Eventually, you'd get crushed,
right?
But--because nothing would be
able to stop the inexorable
collapse down to a singularity
at that point.
But yeah, that is a potential
end of the Universe,
is-- we all end up inside a big
event horizon.
We all collapse down to a
singularity in the middle.
It turns out,
that isn't what's going to
happen--at least,
not from current observations.
The current observation is that
the Universe is expanding faster
than its own escape velocity.
So, you have the opposite
ending point where it just keeps
getting bigger and bigger,
and more and more diffuse and
sparse, and cold and boring,
and the Universe ends that way.
But again, that's part three of
the course.
We'll get there.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Where does all the
mass go when it collapses?
The mass is still there.
And this is actually a very
important point,
because things can still be in
orbit around a black hole and
not fall in.
Because, when you're far enough
away, when you're outside the
event horizon,
it just behaves like any other
mass.
Black holes can move through
space.
They can orbit around other
things.
Things can orbit around them.
If the Sun turned into a black
hole right now,
well, we would freeze.
But aside from that,
the orbit of the Earth--if the
Sun turned into a black hole of
the same mass as the Earth,
the orbit of the Earth wouldn't
change, because we're far enough
away that it just seems like any
other mass down there.
So, a solar mass black hole
could have a planet in exactly
the same orbit as the Earth is
around the Sun.
This is one of the differences
between how black holes actually
behave and the metaphorical use
of black holes.
You know, this is one of those
words that gets used in common
culture for various things,
and it usually carries a
connotation of a kind of great
sucking thing that pulls
everything in,
inexorably.
That's true inside the event
horizon, which is where this
idea arises from.
But, if you're outside the
event horizon,
you can just keep going around
in circles around it,
in exactly the same way that
you can be in orbit around any
other kind of mass.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Why is there no
volume?
Ah, okay.
So, why is there no volume with
this stuff at the center?
If there's nothing to--think
about what we were talking
about, hydrostatic equilibrium,
the other day.
If there's nothing to stop the
collapse, every--if there's no
energy or pressure force
sufficient to stop the collapse,
everything has to end up in the
same place.
It all falls to the center.
And, you can calculate how long
that will take.
And after that happens,
all the mass is down at the
center.
What does it mean to be the
center?
It's the central point.
Now, in fact,
there's got to be--this is how
it works in relativity.
Relativity does not incorporate
quantum mechanics.
Quantum mechanics does funny
things when things get small.
And so, it is likely that there
are physical effects that we
don't understand at the quantum
level before you get to
precisely the same point--but we
don't know what they are,
because that would require a
theory that encompasses
special--general relativity and
quantum mechanics at the same
time.
And until the string theorists
finish their work,
we don't have such a theory.
So, probably something happens
to prevent a pure point,
but we don't know what it is.
And so, from the point of view
on the outside,
you just imagine everything
falling down toward a central
point, and kind of landing there
in some way.
But it is a mystery. Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Is the Universe
finite?
Yes.
It's got to--in fact,
you know it has to be finite,
because the sky is dark at
night.
Let me explain that.
If the Universe were infinite
and had stars distributed at
random throughout the Universe,
then any direction you looked
at, you'd eventually see the
surface of a star.
You could do this in a calculus
kind of way by integrating over
the total light of the Universe.
And so, it can't be infinite in
extent, and filled with
stars--the same as stars like
the Sun,
or any kind of star,
really, that is distributed
evenly.
So, one of several things must
be the case.
Either the Universe is
inhomogeneous--that is to say,
we live in a very special place
where there are stars--after a
while there are no stars
anymore.
Or, it has to be finite in
extent.
It only goes out a certain
distance and stops.
Or, it has to be finite in time.
That is to say,
it began a certain number of
years ago, and didn't exist
before that.
That helps you,
because then you only--if
it's--if the Universe is 13
billion years old,
you only see things that are
within 13 billion light years,
because the light hasn't had a
chance to travel.
It turns out that it's pro--the
easiest way to understand this
is, it's the latter.
The Universe had a beginning.
And this is the whole idea of
The Big Bang--that it started as
some kind of very small object,
and then expanded at some
finite and indeed calculable
time ago.
The Universe is now thought to
be, I think it's 13.7,
plus or minus 0.4 billion years
old.
And so, the finiteness of the
Universe is--at the moment,
is--the primary reason it's
finite is that it's finite in
time,
not so much that it's finite in
space.
But, it has to be limited in
some way, or you'd see an
infinite amount of starlight.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Excellent.
If the Universe is finite,
what's outside the Universe?
That is exactly the right
question.
I can't answer that,
because--although I will try in
section three of the course.
We'll learn much more about
this stuff.
I can't answer that because,
you know, what is the Universe?
The Universe is what we can
study, scientifically.
And so, the very first question
that a sensible person has about
The Big Bang and the finite
Universe is what's outside it.
And that's actually not a
science question,
because it's intrinsically
unanswerable by scientific
means.
Now, there are things you can
say about it,
just as there are things you
can say about the inside of an
event horizon.
And you can base them on
scientific ideas and scientific
thinking, and you can say these
nice things about space and
time.
And one could say similar
things about what's outside the
Universe and,
you know, how it might have
come to be and so forth.
But you've done a little
epistemological shift when you
start talking about those kinds
of things,
because you're no longer
talking about things that,
even in principle,
can be verified by observation
or experiment.
So, I do have some things to
say about that.
I'll say it in the third part
of the course when we talk about
the Universe.
But you should think about what
I have to say about that in a
different way from what
you--from what you think about
what I have to say about how
planets orbit around the Sun.
We'll come back to this later.
Yes, go ahead.
Student: I was just
curious about the black holes.
How do they find them?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: How do they find
them?
That's the next three weeks of
the course.
That--and, in fact,
that is subject of my research.
This is what I do for a living.
I find black holes,
and I'll tell you how it's
done.
We can see if we can find
another one over the next few
weeks or so.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Ah,
is it possible that we are
inside an event horizon and we
don't know it?
Yes, in that--again,
this relates to the question
that was asked over here.
Could it be that the Universe
is going to ultimately collapse
and be inside a black hole?
Supposing that happened.
Supposing we were in the
collapsing phase of the
Universe, gradually,
over many billions of years,
falling down to some
singularity;
we would not necessarily know
that.
Now, if you approach a black
hole that is of the size of a
star, or even the size of a
galaxy--when you got close,
you'd feel it.
And the way you'd feel it is,
is if you're falling in,
your feet would be closer to
the center than your head.
And the gravitational force on
your feet would be stronger than
that on your head,
and you'd stretch.
And so, if we were really near
to a black hole of a size of
objects we understand,
then we'd know that,
because the tidal force is on
our bodies would mean that we
couldn't keep ourselves
together.
But, you could imagine a
sufficiently big black hole,
kind of encompassing the whole
Universe, that wouldn't affect
us in that way.
So, it's not inconceivable.
Yeah?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah,
so the word "reverse" in this
"reverse space and time"--how
about this: I agree that
might--that wording might not
be--I've seen this wording used,
which is why I used it.
But I agree that it might not
be the best wording one could
use.
How about, the properties of
space and the properties of time
are interchanged with each
other?
That's--then it doesn't have
this kind of directional thing.
It's about how these things
behave.
Yeah?
Student: Do we get--does
the Earth get any heat from
other stars than the Sun?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes.
Well, of course,
we do.
If you look out in the sky,
you see stars.
We see the radiation from those
stars.
And so, of course,
there's radiation in all forms,
heat and otherwise.
The fraction of the radiation
that we get from sources other
than the Sun is extremely small.
The-- Student:
[Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: No.
No, because--and here's why:
because, the second most
prominent source of heat that we
have is actually geothermal heat
from the center of the Earth.
And that's vastly more than the
sum of all contributions by
stars.
And it's vastly less than what
we get from the--from our own
Sun.
And so, you know,
radioactivity and the latent
heat in the core of the Earth,
that's, by far,
more than anything that comes
to us from the stars.
But, we certainly do get energy
radiation from the stars.
If we didn't,
astronomers would be out of
business, because this is how
we--this is how we study them,
by looking at the radiation.
Yeah?
Student: Okay,
so let's say that you're inside
the event horizon of a black
hole and--as I remember,
the circular velocity of any
object is less than the escape
velocity?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Uh-huh.
Student: So couldn't you
theoretically orbit the black
hole inside the event horizon
after the circular velocity?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Ah,
excellent question.
Could you orbit--could you get
yourself into a stable orbit
inside an event horizon?
If everything were in--worked
the way Newtonian mechanics says
it works, you could.
But, it turns out,
there are relativistic
corrections.
There is something called the
smallest circular--smallest--the
Innermost Circular Stable Orbit.
IC--ISCO, Innermost Stable
Circular Orbit.
That's important,
because that actually can be
observed in various ways,
and we'll talk about this in
two weeks' time.
The Innermost Stable Circular
Orbit turns out to be outside
the event horizon.
But, you're right,
if you were only using
Newtonian calculations,
there would be that square root
of 2,
and you could imagine being in
a circular orbit inside the
event horizon.
But that's one of the things
that is different about the
relativistic calculation.
It turns out that for
non-rotating black holes the
Innermost Stable Circular Orbit
is three times the Schwarzschild
radius.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Ah,
yes.
So, is there a potential for a
black hole to accumulate an
infinite amount of mass,
which is the sort of vacuum
cleaner scenario?
First of all,
there isn't an infinite amount
of mass in the Universe,
necessarily.
The Universe is finite.
Second of all,
even if there was,
if there was a huge black hole
here, and something else outside
the event horizon that's moving
faster than the escape velocity
of this thing,
at that point,
then it doesn't fall in.
So, it's not necessarily true
that it will pile up an infinite
amount of mass.
In fact, black holes--black
holes ought not to have infinite
mass.
They ought to have a particular
amount of mass.
They'll gain more as stuff
falls, but if stuff doesn't fall
in, if it's moving faster than
the escape velocity,
then they won't accumulate it.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well it depends what
you have--we observed extremely
massive holes.
It depends what you mean by
"extremely massive."
The mass--most massive black
holes that we know anything
about are about three billion
times the mass of the Sun.
So, that's pretty massive,
but it's about the same as an
ordinary galaxy.
And we--what we don't have
evidence for is black holes that
are substantially more massive
than whole galaxies of stars.
We don't--there's no evidence
for that.
So they're, basically--just to
jump ahead, they're basically
two kinds of black holes that we
have empirical evidence for.
One are black holes the--about
ten times the mass of the Sun.
So, masses of individual stars.
Then there are the so-called
supermassive black holes,
which are the masses of whole
galaxies,
and those are the kinds of
black holes for which we have
direct evidence at the moment.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Okay,
so, is it possible to detect
the presence of a black hole by
looking at things around it?
Yes.
That's exactly what is done,
and we'll--I'll describe this
in the next couple of weeks.
But, it doesn't happen the way
you suggest.
It's not like something
suddenly disappears,
so we know it fell into the
event horizon.
What you do is you see these
things in stable orbits
around--that are perfectly happy
going around in circles,
around the black hole.
For example,
you can see binary stars,
double stars,
in which there's a black hole
and something else.
And these things are in nice
stable orbits,
and you infer the properties of
one object by looking at the
motion of the other object.
That's exactly what we did for
the planets.
And so, you can do that again
for black holes.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: If you actually saw
something disappearing?
Yeah, and in fact there
is--there is indirect evidence
that there's material falling
through--that in some systems
there is material currently
falling through the event
horizon of black holes.
And, in fact,
that's one of the things that
is a current topic of active
research, is,
can you demonstrate that?
If there were a black hole in
our own Solar System,
anywhere near us,
we'd know it.
And the reason we'd know it is,
that's a lot of mass.
It would disrupt the orbits of
the planets.
And as long as the planets--and
so, we have a kind of early
warning system.
If a black hole cruises by,
Pluto's orbit gets disturbed
first.
And so, all of those nice
objects out there in the Kuiper
Belt, their orbits would go all
haywire if something as massive
as a stellar mass black hole
were accidentally to come
nearby,
in exactly the same way they
would be as if an ordinary star
of the same mass were to come
by.
You wouldn't be able to see it,
but the orbits of everything
would be changed rather
drastically.
So, the odds of us actually
falling into a black hole are
extremely small,
and if it were to happen,
we'd get a great deal of
advance notice.
So, not to worry.
There are astronomical things
you maybe should worry about,
asteroids crashing into the
Earth, this isn't one of them.
Actually, Bethany Cobb and I
were on a TV show that explored
this particular possibility.
This is a wonderful thing.
It happened last summer,
where ABC News decided to have
a two-hour special on all the
different ways the Earth could
be destroyed.
And they called us up,
and we went down to New York.
It was very entertaining,
and you know--but,
I was too much of a scientist.
I kept saying it isn't going to
happen.
You shouldn't worry about it.
You know, you should worry
about the asteroids and global
warming, and all this kind of
stuff.
Don't be worrying about black
holes coming rolling in.
And, of course,
the consequence of that is that
I didn't get a lot of screen
time.
And the guys from the American
Museum of Natural History,
who were better at popularizing
science than I am,
got all the screen time.
So, you know, I know better now.
We'll speak in better sound
bites next time around.
Yeah, that was fun.
But we should screen it,
you know, or at least the first
part.
Other questions?
All will become clear in due
time.
Actually, that's not true.
But some things will become
clear in real time.
Gosh, this was great, excellent.
All sorts of questions.
So now, let me at least start
talking about special
relativity.
There are two kinds of
There's special relativity--and
special relativity,
which was devised in 1905 by
Einstein--this is essentially a
set of laws of motion.
So, it's the same thing as
Newton's Laws of Motion,
only it's a more elaborate
version of it.
So it substitutes,
if you will,
for Newton's Laws of Motion,
and in fact,
incorporates Newton's Laws of
Motion.
Then there's general
relativity, discovered about ten
years later, again by Einstein.
And this is the equivalent of a
law of gravity.
You'll remember that the way
one has to calculate orbits in
the Newtonian Theory is,
you take Newton's Law of
Gravity and you plug it into
Newton's Laws of Motion.
So, this is a change,
or an enhancement,
in the laws of motion.
This is a change or an
enhancement in the law of
gravity.
In both of these cases  and
this is important to realize
it doesn't overturn what Newton
did.
This is a misconception about
how scientific revolutions work.
This is as revolutionary a set
of ideas as you could possibly
imagine.
And yet, Newton's laws
are--still hold.
They don't overturn them.
What they do is,
they say, Newton's laws are not
general laws,
but laws that only operate in
certain specific situations.
These are now the general laws
that operate always,
and Newton's calculations are a
subset of these things that only
work under certain conditions.
And just to jump ahead a little
bit--the condition is,
there's a quantity--so,
now I'm going to talk,
first, about special
relativity.
We'll leave gravity until later.
But now, let's just talk about
how things move.
And this is important,
because this gives rise to the
limit on--to the limit on
velocity.
All velocities must be left
less than or equal to the speed
of light.
You can't go faster than the
speed of light.
And just to jump ahead,
the way Newton's Laws of Motion
relate to special relativity is
through a parameter,
a quantity called gamma [].
And this is equal to this
quantity.
1 - V^(2) /
c^(2),
the square root of that,
in the denominator.
Okay.
1 / (1 - V^(2) /
c^(2))^(1/2) And when
V is much,
much less than the speed of
light, then gamma is equal to 1.
You can see.
If this--if V is much
less than the speed of light,
this quantity is more or less
zero.
You got 1 / 1.
Gamma = 1.
Newtonian physics assumes that
gamma is equal to 1.
So, this leads directly to all
of Newtonian physics.
But, as velocities start to get
higher, gamma starts to be
different from 1.
And if--as V approaches
the speed of light,
what's going to happen?
This is going--if V is
the speed of light,
V^(2) / c^(2)
= 1.
You've got 1 - 1 in the
denominator, so you've got zero
in the denominator.
So, as V approaches the
speed of light,
gamma approaches infinity.
And then you get--so,
you start to get these
relativistic effects.
So, it turns out,
for example,
in relativistic physics,
that mass isn't exactly what
Newton thought mass was.
Mass is what's called the rest
mass;
this is the Newtonian
mass--times gamma.
So, if everything's moving
slowly, and gamma = 1,
then the mass is exactly what
Newton thought it was going to
be.
It's a property of objects.
It's constant.
It doesn't change.
Mass is conserved and you can
do all the wonderful
calculations that you can do in
Newtonian gravity.
Now, the properties of gamma
are such--remember this goes to
infinity--that,
therefore, as the velocity goes
to the speed of light,
the mass approaches infinity,
because gamma approaches
infinity.
And you're multiplying the
Newtonian mass by some number
that's getting larger and larger
and larger and larger as you get
closer to the speed of light.
Now, what does this mean?
Remember Newton's Laws of
Motion.
Let's go all the way back to
Newton.
This is--force is equal to mass
times acceleration.
Yeah, go ahead.
Student: What does gamma
stand for?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Gamma is a parameter
that tells you how relativistic
you are.
It is defined by this.
So, it's a function of your
velocity.
Yeah.
And whether--and how--how much
bigger than 1 it is tells you
how far away from the Newtonian
Theory relativity is.
And, the faster you go--the
closer you get to the speed of
light, the more relativistic you
become and the less Newtonian
you are.
So, it's a parameter that tells
you how close you are to Newton.
Other questions, yes?
Student: How exactly is
gamma derived?
[inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: How was gamma
derived?
I'll talk about the history of
this next time,
but basically it was--Einstein
revised the Laws of Motion in
response to some experiments,
which weren't giving the right
Newtonian answer.
That's the short version,
and we'll do the long version
next time.
And, it was the genius of
Einstein that he recognized how
it--how the Laws of Motion
should be modified,
and indeed that they should be
modified at all,
which was not most other
people's initial reaction to
these experiments.
Okay, so now,
what happens if your mass
becomes infinite?
Right?
That means for a--remember this
is acceleration,
and this is force.
If your mass becomes infinite
then F / M,
which is equal to the
acceleration,
this goes to zero,
which means you cannot have any
acceleration,
no matter how much force you
apply.
And that's why you can't go
faster than the speed of light.
Right?
Because as you get closer and
closer to the speed of light,
this gamma factor becomes
larger and larger.
That makes your mass larger and
larger.
And then, to get a given amount
of acceleration,
since this is huge,
you have to have an increasing
amount of force.
By the time you get to the
speed of light the mass
is--sorry, it's this whole thing
that's zero, not the mass.
By the time you get to the
speed of light,
you need an infinite amount of
force to accelerate yourself.
So, you need an infinite amount
of force in order to go faster.
And so, by the time you get out
to the speed of light,
you can't go faster,
because it would take an
infinite amount of force to do
so.
Yes?
Student: Does that mean
that when you're traveling the
speed of light,
not only can you not speed up,
but you also can't slow down,
since it would take force to
slow you down?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: That's right,
and what it really means,
though,
is that nothing with a non-zero
mass can actually ever get to
the speed of light.
And therefore, what about light?
Light has zero mass.
It has to, otherwise it can't
go at the speed of light.
So if M_zero
is zero, then this whole thing
applies in a very different way.
And so anything that goes at
the speed of light has to be
massless, for just this kind of
reason.
Yeah?
Student: If light is
energy then doesn't it have a
mass equivalent?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: It has a mass
equivalent, but its rest mass is
zero.
So, the reason it has energy is
because you've got zero times
infinity.
And so, if you slow light down,
then it disappears altogether.
Right?
Because--if you slow light in a
vacuum down, I should specify,
it disappears altogether,
because if this isn't infinite
and this is zero,
then you've got no mass energy
at all.
Yes?
Student: If you can't
accelerate or decelerate,
how do you get to your sort of
intrinsic velocity?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well,
what is an intrinsic velocity?
This is where relativity
becomes relative.
Depends on how fast the person
who's observing you is going.
But remember,
this only applies if you're
already moving at the speed of
light.
If you're not moving at the
speed of light,
then this isn't infinite.
You have some finite mass and
you can change your velocity.
Remember, acceleration is a
change in velocity by applying
force.
And as long as the mass isn't
infinite, it just--you know,
you calculate how much force it
takes.
And that's how much it takes to
change your velocity.
Other questions?
Excellent questions all around.
This is not at all
straightforward and we will
continue next time.
00:47:60